I feel like there's a very real chance
that by the end of this challenge I'm
just gonna have lost all my followers
hey guys I'm Brett and like basically
every other millennial out there I'm
addicted to my Instagram I obsess over
filters and a witty caption and shadows
and highlights and contrasts it's a lot
so this week I'm gonna challenge my
friend jasmine to be a hundred percent
honest on Instagram here's what that's
gonna look like one we have to post once
a day two we have to only use the preset
filters in the app three the caption has
to be a hundred percent in the moment
for these posts have to be done in three
minutes or less
three minutes is not a long time this is
gonna be really really tough and I'm
gonna hate this by the end if she's up
for it we'll give it a go this is
probably gonna suck under three minutes
to edit my photo only an Instagram to
pick out a caption that is true to what
I'm feeling all in three minutes so I
think day one's gonna be okay I'm about
to take a bootcamp class with Peter from
The Bachelor so that's a high point in
life sharing and I'm Shane ringing glass
just got out I got to meet him but I got
sick in the bathroom right before I met
him and that is something I would
completely keep to myself normally maybe
I'll try being honest and mention it to
maybe because I picked a pretty tame
caption but I feel like this
I'm gonna be a hoe so that might be a
different type of caption outcome but
we'll see just posted for day two and
that's getting less likes been some of
my other posts and I lost a follower
which kind of hurts
I guess that's to be expected from then
a trash Instagram me on social media is
the exact me you will get in real life
I'm not trying to get fish any of y'all
like I'm just a thick Saudi [ __ ] that's
my aesthetic here so I had the right
idea to take a picture outside
[Music]
I think posting a selfie for this
challenge is gonna be harder though by
far the thing I missed the most about
this week is vscocam there are certain
little tiny fixes that go a long way and
I mix them a lot
69
if anything maybe out of this experiment
maybe I'll just feel a little bit more
comfortable posting some regular selfies
throughout the week I haven't been
feeling like the best about myself
lately
so I wrote that in the caption it was
weird within like 20 minutes I had 80
comments of people just like uplifting
me and giving me compliments you always
look so confident all the time so it's
nice to see this side of you the more
real you are in your captions the more
people like actually want to see that I
tried to think a little different with
this post I was like a little bit more
personal and open on Instagram about
something that I would usually never
post about I like went to therapy for
the first time in a normal context
outside of this challenge I never would
have felt totally comfortable sharing
that I got some really good feedback
immediately and it was kind of nice just
letting that out there too it kind of
made me realize that I wasn't alone in
that sense it was a nice outcome on a
picture that I wasn't really thrilled
for it like meant so much more to me
that so many people were just like no
like you're an awesome person and you
need to realize that sometimes the
internet doesn't suck just snapped a
quick selfie at the dentist's office
because I just wanted my post to be done
for the day although it's super
unflattering and I still can't talk
because my mouth is numb my post is done
de-stress is over with for the day and
then
back to my regular instagram evans thank
god
earlier today i posted a picture like
laughing on the sidewalk with some crazy
ass makeup and i was shocked to see that
so many people were so supportive there
were people that were like yes thank you
for being the voice of the curves
I don't know I'm happy with it and I
don't think I'll delete it later we are
finally done with the challenge while
there were plenty parts of that that I I
didn't really like at all it wasn't all
bad and I think there's like some
highlights from it I think my favorite
post that I did was when I posted about
therapy for the first time I think for
me Instagram is this thing where it's
usually like picture perfect it was nice
to change that and be a little bit more
honest I think the hardest part about
this social media challenge was the fact
that I had to post every day feeling
good five days in a row to post a
picture for a lot of people to see was a
lot it's really great because every post
that I put up being completely honest in
I got so many nice comments there were
like you go girl or yes you've inspired
me to do this or yes you've inspired me
to love myself and I'm just like I want
to keep doing that for people if I take
anything from this it'll be that every
once in a while maybe it doesn't hurt to
be honest on Instagram I've never felt
so loved from my Instagram in the past
week I don't know I think I'm gonna keep
all this up this was a great challenge
thanks for the experience
[Music]